-You guys, Christmas is just
five days away.
That's right.
I saw that Google
has a Santa Tracker,
where you can watch Santa's
journey around the world.
Yeah.
Yeah, not to be outdone,
Facebook has a tracker
where you can steal Santa's
Social Security number.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Isn't that nice?
-Yeah.
-It has his Spotify playlist.
-Aw.
-But with just
five days until Christmas,
we're reaching the point
where any toys you order online
won't arrive in time.
[ Light laughter ]
Right now, every
closed Toys 'R' Us is like,
"How you like me now?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Now you like me?
Now you like Toys 'R' Us?"
Well, I heard
that a popular gift this year
are those personal
DNA testing kits.
You know those?
They're pretty cool.
You send in your sample,
and then after a few weeks,
you get a letter back that says,
"Sir, that cup was for saliva."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Indeed!
-"I thought
you wanted a stool sample."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
I thought they'd
need a stool sample,
a semen sample,
and a urine sample.
-Oh, and what did you send them?
-My underwear.
[ Laughter ]
-Guys --
-Oldy but a goldy.
-Guys, uh...
[ Laughter ]
I read that
even though fewer people
send physical mail nowadays,
a lot of people still send
holiday greeting cards,
including celebrities.
It's very nice.
Look at some of the homemade
cards they've written this year.
For example,
Seth Rogen wrote,
"O Christmas tree,
O Christmas tree."
You open it up it says,
"You're not the only thing
I'm lighting tonight."
Isn't that nice?
-Wow.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, he has beautiful
penmanship, too.
-Supreme Court
Justice Brett Kavanaugh wrote,
"It's time for my favorite
holiday tradition."
You open it up, it says,
"Chugging eggnog
through a funnel."
-Wow!
-What?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Former Trump attorney
Michael Cohen wrote,
"Last Christmas,
I gave you my heart."
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Open it up, it says,
"But only because I was acting
under direct orders
from Individual 1."
-Wow.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Found an Olde English font.
-And, finally, Cardi B wrote,
"It's beginning
to look a lot like..."
You open it up, it says,
"O-Chrrristmas."
There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So much better
than a store-bought card.
-Yeah. Why would you want one?
You want a homemade.
-Yeah.
-You can tell care went into it.
-Guys, I saw that tomorrow,
President Trump leaves
for a 16-day trip to Mar-A-Lago,
where he'll have his annual
Christmas party.
And just to mess with him,
the only song the deejay
will play is "Feliz Navidad."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Can we put a wall
in front of the deejay?"
[ Laughter ]
"Can't see the deejay."
-"We can't see him."
-Here's a big story.
Trump wants
to go against his advisers
and pull U.S. troops
out of Syria.
I'm not sure Trump should be
making this decision,
'cause he thinks Syria
is the voice on his iPhone.
He's like,
"Syria, build me a border wall.
In front of that deejay!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Of course,
Trump is always in the news,
and sometimes, he's saying
some pretty questionable things,
and while we can't filter
what he says,
we can filter
how he looks when he says it.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for Trump Filters.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Great lawyers
that do that stuff,
they're saying,
"There's nothing illegal."
-All right.
We'll get to that in a second.
-No, no.
Wait a minute.
I mean,
when you tell me I'm at 50%,
I say,
"How can I possibly be at 50%?"
So, when you tell me
I'm at 48 --
Like, Rasmussen,
I was at 50% in Rasmussen.
-With this type
of approval rating,
what do you say to a --
I think I have the greatest base
in the history of politics.
[ Applause ]
-Interesting.
-You guys, listen to this.
In a speech this morning,
Russian President Vladimir Putin
said that he'd like
to get married again someday.
Yeah, very interesting.
When you see Putin on Tinder
and try to swipe left,
your phone says, "Try again."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Think about it."
[ Laughter ]
This made me laugh.
An aquarium in California
tweeted a picture of a sea otter
with some memes
about its weight,
and then a local news anchor
decided to read the memes
on air.
It was just a little awkward.
Watch this.
-An otter from
the Monterey Bay Aquarium
is getting major attention
from the Internet
after the aquarium
sent out this tweet,
writing, and we quote,
"Abbie is a thick girl.
What an absolute unit.
She is C-H-O-N-K.
Look at the size of this lady.
Oh, Lawd, she coming,"
another Internetism.
[ Laughter ]
-She -- She chonk.
"She's C-H-O-N-K."
[ Laughter ]
It sounds like a vice principal
trying to bond with students.
He's like, "You know
what's always on fleek?
Respect."
[ Laughter ]
"And doing your homework."
"This parent teacher conference
is lit."
[ Laughter ]
Check this out.
I heard that Budweiser
is partnering
with a medical marijuana company
to make weed-infused beer.
Budweiser said,
"If 2019's anything like 2018,
you're gonna want this."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"A staple in the fridge."
That's right -- Budweiser
is making beer with marijuana.
There's actually a name for beer
that's infused with weed.
Nyquil.
[ Laughter ]
Get this -- I read that workout
clothes made out of velvet
are becoming very popular.
Velvet workout clothes,
or as it's known in New Jersey,
formal wear.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, hey, oh!
-Excuse me.
Whoa.
[ Laughter ]
-Forget about it.
-Excuse me.
[ Laughter ]
-I need a velour cummerbund.
-You guys,
it's almost New Year's,
and since it's been a crazy year
with Trump in office,
we thought we'd look back
and count down
his top moments from 2018.
Enjoy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Five.
-China has total respect
for Donald Trump,
and for Donald Trump's
very, very large a-brain.
-Four.
-You need to vote
for Scott Walker
and Lea Vukm-i-i-i-ir.
[ Laughter ]
-Three.
♪♪♪♪
-Two.
-Merry Christmas, everybody.
-One.
-Father Herman is looking down.
He's very proud of you
right now.
-Oh, he's still alive.
-Oh, he is?
Well, then he --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"He's still alive."
-"Oh, is he?"
"He's still alive."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-And, finally,
it's time for
"Tonight Show News Blender,"
where we take
real headlines from the week
and blend them together
to see how weird
we can make the headlines.
I'll show you what I mean.
For example,
if you blend the stories
"Charity spends money
on Trump self-portrait,"
"Kool-Aid Man
stars in new rap video,"
and, "Company with low Internet
speed owes millions."
You get
"Trump spends millions
on portrait of Kool-Aid Man
in a speedo."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
-Weirder headlines.
-I believe it.
Next up,
if you the blend the stories,
"Wrinkle cream
makes list of worst gifts,"
"Post Office
delivers 900 million packages,"
and "Nudist retreat for sale,"
you get, "Post Office
delivers wrinkle cream
to 900 nudists
for their packages."
-Whoa!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Next up,
if you blend the stories,
"Trump goes after tax cuts
for booze,"
"'All I Want
for Christmas is You,'
is top song every year,"
and "Tweet defends
Sarah Huckabee Sanders,"
you get,
"After every Trump tweet,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders sings
'All I want for Christmas
is booze.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And finally,
if you blend the stories,
"Critics say Bernie Sanders
too old for 2020,"
"Massive explosion
caused by spray cans,"
and "Man finds soiled underwear
in sushi delivery,"
you get,
"Bernie Sanders eats old sushi,
soils underwear
in massive can explosion."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Guys,
we have a great show tonight!
Give it up for The Roots!